[Music]
imagine
earth covered in thick sheets of ice
and sea levels so low you could walk
to a different continent this
is what our planet would look like
during an ice age
there have been five of them in earth's
history and
they've had a huge impact on our present
world
now try and imagine an earth where
these ice ages never existed in the
first place
what ecosystems would change
would humans have evolved
and why do i say just happen
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if the ice age never happened
over a century ago milutin milankovic
hypothesized that
changes in the earth's orbit the angle
of its axis
and the direction of its axis are what
create
long-term changes to the climate known
as
milankovitch cycles they create the
seasons we know well
and the ice ages that we're glad to have
skipped
but what if milankovitch cycles didn't
exist without milankovitch cycles
earth would look a lot different
there would have been no ice ages none
at all
which means no glaciers to carve out
beautiful inland lakes and valleys
it also means earth's flora and fauna
would have evolved differently grasses
initially popped up on earth before the
first ice age but
they truly thrived as the earth became
cooler and drier
grasslands tundras and savannas grew
all over the earth replacing dense
forests
with no cooling period leading up to the
first ice age
grasses would not have spread so easily
there would be less variety and the
animals that evolved to eat grass
would be less abundant horses giraffes
cows gazelles any animal you associate
with dry grasslands
would have had less habitat to flourish
instead there would be more rainforests
left on earth
the climate in general would be warmer
and wetter
and what about the animals that rained
during the ice ages
well we wouldn't know of any
saber-toothed cats
giant sloths mastodons woolly mammoths
probably would never have graced our
planet
but what about us
[Music]
well homo erectus first emerged during
the last big ice age in the pleistocene
epic
this is the same time that woolly
mammoths roamed the world
a general hypothesis is that the extreme
climate forced the evolution of homo
erectus
they had to change their diets from
mostly plants
to half plants and half meat which
increased their brain size they
developed
the use of tools and they had to migrate
to seek more hospitable land
without the ice age forcing the need for
adaptation and
evolution humans would probably not
exist
which also means our present earth
wouldn't have any of the human induced
climate changes we're witnessing today
even if homo erectus which preceded homo
sapiens
evolved regardless of the ice age our
progress as a species would change many
scientists
attribute agriculture to the rapid
growth and global expansion of humans
but without the ice age we could have
developed the benefits of agriculture
sooner in the absence of dry arid
grasslands
we also might have advanced different
farming practices which
favored forest foods our diet might
consist of
fewer plants from the grass family like
wheat and oats
and more fruits and vegetables
for evolution to occur it needs a
catalyst
like an ice age earth as we know it
today
exists because cycles and catalysts
have pushed living organisms to adapt it
would be
a very different planet without
milankovitch cycles and
the ice ages they produce even greater
than this
how different would earth be if it
completely stopped its orbit
around the sun
well that's a story for another
what if
[Music]